hello everyone and the good news
everyone the books I ordered on the 1972
World Chess Championship match between
Bobby Fischer and Boris Spassky in
Reykjavik have almost arrived I believe
tomorrow or a day after tomorrow they
will arrive the one by citizen legalish
and the other one by Larry Evans so
we'll be returning to our Bobby Fischer
series fairly soon until that happens I
decided to check up on some of your
other suggestions several of them were
about yesterday's match speeches
championship matches that come between
polish grandmaster young Chris of Duda
and 2015 bullets world champion
Alexander Gary shook so definitely a
tough matchup and a very serious matchup
for her for young grandmaster Duda who
is that well you could say that he is a
prodigy a chess prodigy as he did get
his Grandmaster title at the age of 15
and this is the this is the
quarterfinals finals of the championship
so we're going to talk about the results
of the match after this game a bit more
so without further ado
Duda has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 I will have Knight to f6 and
Bishop to g5 Duda goes for the trump
offski attack but we have g6 but
captures on f6 early giving up with the
bishop repair he captures on f6 and now
c4 so black will now have the bishop
pair but his pawn structure has been
somewhat compromised d5c captures on d5
Queen captures on d5 and now Knight to
c3 Queen back to the 8th as the Queen
was attacked and now comes a III a very
nice principled move placing your all
your points on dark squares as you do
only have a light square bishop to
develop a Bishop to e7 Bishop to c4 and
now c6 again a nice move by Grigio
controlling the night here and also
preparing some Queen side expansion
Knight G to E - and now Bishop to d6 as
do that I decided to develop the knight
via e3 and not via lvie - and not VI f3
good issue besides the bishop will be
much better placed on d6
so now perhaps castling kingside would
be a bit too premature as black already
would have
a nice Bishop here to attack the
kingside so instead Duda was h4 now if
Greece should besides the Castle
kingside then dude already has upon an
h4 and he can simply start attacking it
via upon 2 H 5 if you've ever used the
for example Chessmaster I believe it's
just me 11 grandmaster edition there is
a very nice Academy by Josh Waitzkin
there and he would often mention that he
is he when he was younger his coach
bruce pandolfini often called this h
bone a ram sort of like a battering ram
that's this used to knock down doors on
castles I always thought that was a that
was a very nice piece of information so
you know there we have it we have h5
grace Chuck doesn't allow this h5 to
happen from White Queen to c2 and now
Knight to d7 as this is a blitz game the
entire speeches championship match is
sort of a first to play a couple of buds
games until you run out of time then you
play like three minutes games and then
after that you play bullet games this is
from the five minutes and the one second
increment section and here it would be
easy to blunder since it is a boy's game
for example if you castles if you castle
notice that the F pawn is pinned so
queen capture some g6 would be more than
enough to win you the game here for
white it's ok after Queen c2 Knight to
d7 now we have Queen that castle and now
Knight to b6 very short attacks the
bishop on on c4 Bishop to b3 and now
Queen to e7 castling is still out of the
question
due to the same queen g6 idea came to be
won and now King to f8 a very nice idea
but you disagree Shakur decides not to
castle artificially as you know we
already saw what happens if you if you
just castle
efore by Duda and now comes came to g7 s
planned we have king - a1 you don't want
to keep your king and queen on the same
diagonal when black has a dark square
bishop it could a Bishop to a5 move for
example could be very unpleasant if it
becomes possible in the future so you
know better better be safe
King to a 1 and now a5 as the King is
now safely tucked away on a1 Grisha
decides to start his own attack
on the queenside a4 will not renew the
bishops in say for his guard three times
but you know just opening a semi opening
the a file would be a very nice start of
an attack for black so a3 making some
room for the bishop on a date - yeah
butter up the c7 and then out comes f4
we have Bishop to g4 a nice developing
move also opening denied any - and now
II five good besides the tries to close
the center we have f5 and the now comes
the rook to d3 unpinning now the knight
can move and this rook will perhaps be
free to roam around rock h to d8 agree
she decides to develop a rook on the d
file and now comes Knight the g3 not the
greatest square for the knight perhaps
but you know it's better than being on e
- we have a rock to see it now aligning
the rook with the Queen on the C file
and also pretty much the only square
where you can develop the rook Bishop to
a2 again a very nice move by Judah as
simply trying to play something
developing like rook e1 or c1 would run
into this c5 move which would be very
unpleasant since the bishop is kind of
awkwardly placed here now c4 would be a
pretty big threat so again simply
improving the position Bishop 282 first
and two now comes the brush up to b8
black does the same opening up the rook
nice to f1 now the night wasn't really
doing anything on g3 so now a Duda tries
to Riemann over it we have Knight to d5
Bishop captures on d5 we have C captures
on d5 and now Queen to b3 and now you
see it was perhaps somewhat a weird idea
why give up such a strong bishop for
this knight on d5 okay the knight on d5
is also strong and but the idea is that
the pawn on e5 is very weak and this is
what to do that we'll use to you know
use as the means of pushing this game
for more than a draw so Bishop captures
pawn sorry about that
pawn captures and now comes Queen to b3
we have worked to d7 and now Knight to
e3 e3 a pretty nice square for the
knight
again it doesn't doesn't really have all
that many squares but perhaps it will
capture this Bishop at some point and
the bishop really now isn't doing all
that much on g4 Roxy to d8 Andrew now
comes Queen to b5 attacking the a 5:1 we
have Queen to the Queen to b6 and now
comes Queen captures on a5 Bishop to c7
attacking the Queen and now Queen back
to be 5 and now Bishop to b6 blocking
the Queen's attack against the b6 pawn
rook to d2 a very nice move creating
some escaped squares for the for the
Queen and also preparing to double rooks
on the C file bush up to a 7 and the now
comes King to be one king to h6 we have
worked the c1 as planned
King to g7 English cook is simply
waiting to see what what to do this plan
is Queen to b3 now with a lot of
pressure against the d5 pawn king to h6
and now Knight the b5 also a reason why
the Queen was moved from b5 now nice to
b5 is played the bishop is now kicked to
be a to push up to b8 here and now comes
rook to c2 and now do the successful
doubles rook on the C file Queen to e7
and now comes Knight captures on g4 okay
f capture Sanji for Enda now comes the
g3 so what do you do here well it's a
pretty block position but you can you
can pretty much feel White's position is
much better here simply because of the
extra pawn and because the night is a
bit better than this Bishop on b8 that's
really not doing all that much
Queen to e6 is played and now comes Rock
the c8 now Duda finds a way to
infiltrate a griffix position
Queen to f5 check we have King to a2 and
now comes the Queen to e4 and here rook
captures on d8 rock captor sandy 8 and
now comes a for also a possible idea was
Queen to b4 Queen to b4 followed by
Queen to e7 and g5 or if black prevents
the Queen from coming to Eastern than
even Queen to c7
a queen to see fog would be possible and
then
the dark that blacks Queen will not
really be able to move as she will
constantly be have to she'll constantly
have to keep an eye on the d5 pawn but
okay
a4 was played in the game and we have
came to g7 again we should simply wait
to see what will happen
rook the c5 and the now comes Queen back
to g2 also from g2 the queen is
protecting the d5 pawn but also now if
the if the White Queen moves then Queen
captures and g3 is also an idea look
back to see two attacking blacks Queen
we have Queen back to e4 and now rook
back to c3 Queen back to g2 and the now
comes Queen to b4 Duda now goes goes
perhaps for this plan of Queen to e7
we have rook to e8 guruship prevents
this and now comes Queen to c5 we have
Queen back to e4 and now comes Queen to
b6 now with ideas of an infiltrating via
Queen to f6
Queen to e2 okay we have Queen captures
on b7
now the pawn as it was undefended Duda
captures it and now this becomes a
passed a pawn and our blacks position is
very difficult to play but still its
ability bliss game a lot can happen
Queen to d1 with the idea of capturing
the a4 pawn so we have b3 simply
guarding it
Queen to h1 here the queen is now
guarding at the d5 pawn Queen to d7
attacking the rook now comes a rock to
f8 and here ecigs
you can't capture because the DF 7 point
is of course pinned so Queen to e1 we
have e 7 and now comes rook to g8
okay now the Queen and the rook are both
guarding the 8 square you still can
promote so how do you push for the win
here a5
simply push another pass pawn queen to
e2 check we have came to a3 and now
comes Queen to e1 so what do you do here
kink the b4 simply protect the rook on
c3 with the King so now the knight can
move we have Bushnell captures on f4
grisha doesn't really have any more
options you do have to act as you're
pretty much without a move so G captures
and now comes G
three Grichuk sacrifices a piece but at
least he finds a way to activate his own
past bone now and here I move like wink
after Sun d5 regarding the GTO square
would would have been enough for Duda to
win the game for example Queen captures
on a 7 with check King to a4 even Queen
captures on h4 but still white is up a
piece and winning here but it's a
Bullock's game both players are very low
on time here do the play tonight the c7
and here
a gorilla missed his opportunity to to
get to equalize this game and perhaps
since it is a beliefs game to perhaps
get even more than then just equalize
but he didn't find it but you know you
have all the time in the world feel feel
feel free to pause the video and find
the idea agree should missed for black
in this position I'll give it a couple
of seconds as usual for those of you who
were able to find it congratulations you
are an excellent saver of of bad
positions and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show rope to be a
check seems like a pretty
straightforward thing and if you had
more time most likely you would play it
immediately for example if you move the
king then Queen captures on c3 comes and
after you move the King then black will
always be able to keep checking the
White King on the other hand if you
block with the night for example after
work to be a to check you simply going
right back to b5 then g2 comes and you
don't really have a good way of
promoting your past eat pawn
for example Queen d6 attacking the rook
black people just ignore white feel free
to capture my rook I have now two Queens
on the board Queen captures and after
Queen captures on c7 on e7 with check
it's two queens against a rock Knight
and the Queen not not like a totally
great advantage for black but it is a
better position for black a bleed game
and two queens for black so yeah here
nice the c7 was played as we've said and
wasn't really the greatest of moves but
the Grisha playing g2 immediately but
now it's a bit different because here
white has simply d8
another queen into the game we have
Queen to g1 a move that simply doesn't
work for black here what dude I was
expecting was rook captures on e8 and
after Knight captures with Czech allies
the King g8 and now Knight back to d6
and now after black brings another Queen
into the game our Queen captures on f7
with check King to h8 and now Knight to
b5 guarding the d4 pawn and ok you still
can't deliver checkmate immediately
because the rock is pinned but the white
is much better here the king is very
nicely protected here even though black
has two queens the white will what will
very easily win this game but instead
you know it is a blitz game agree ship
simply brought another Queen into the
game and here we have Queen captures on
f7 and when Grisha saw this move he was
really like he didn't see this move so I
mean he was lost either way but when
you're playing a blitz game and you're
very long time of course you hope for
the best always in any position so here
in this position
Alexander Bishop resigned because of
whatever he does it's simply made in one
King to h8 or h6 will be met with Queen
to h7 checkmate so in this position
alexander gurko resigned and an
excellent victory for yan Duda the
Polish Grandmaster who won this entire
match I believe it's 14 to 13 so he
wanted to be only one point difference
and it's very interesting because the
grip was leading the match and at one
point Duda even do they even blundered a
queen in the opening and then he was
able to come back in the match and even
start winning and Indian wind match so a
very impressive win by a Polish
Grandmaster Ian Duda who advances to the
semi-finals he awaits for his opponent
in the speeches championship but like I
said there will be a link in the
description below feel free to check it
out and I do hope you enjoy that as well
so there was the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank ya know
called a group on MIDI potty
Antonio parish and
three new friends from Celine guilt
rates and Aiden keys for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
for the next quest for the quest for
today up until the next quest is you
have to checkmate your opponent with a
pawn so that is the quest best of luck
to everyone and congratulations to
everyone who was able to finish the game
with six nights on the board so that's
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos your think all for watching and I
will see you soon
maybe even we're starting the Spassky
Fischer series thank you all and I'll
see you soon